Four years ago,
my husband
Mike and I
were sitting in a hospital room
when our child, Abby,
was diagnosed with leukemia.
I think anybody who's been
in a life threatening
diagnosis, you know, will
remember those moments
like go in.
She's going to be able to have our chemo,
but she's not going
to have Erwinaze today.
How come it's on shortage?
Obvious, clever.
Nothing gets past her and she just said,
What does this mean?
Does this mean I die?
She asks you that question.
Yeah.
It's hard enough that my nine year
old had to contemplate her mortality
when she was diagnosed with cancer
and also then wondered
if she was going to survive
because not enough drug was made
What she did next
makes her a true champion for change.
She put together a consortium
of friends and family
and they essentially created a phone bank
calling more than 220 children's
hospitals around the country
and asking all of them did
they have the medication
that could save Abby?
Finally, someone said yes,
it was a relief
and a release of all the stress.
And then I felt tremendous guilt,
and I was haunted by the
knowledge that somewhere in the country
some other mom and child
was going to be going through
the same hopeless conversation.
So we launched Angels for Change,
and almost immediately
people began to call.
So right now, we're in a ten year
high for drug shortages.
There's more than 300
essential medicine shortages.
There's four key reasons why
there's shortage.
The lower
the price medicine,
the more likely it is to be in shortage.
The more complicated the medicine is.
There's a history of acute event
that all of it is made by one supplier
or one area of the world.
It's more likely to be in shortage.
I think we've gotten
so used to thinking
about things like Amazon.
They can anticipate
when you're running out of toilet paper,
when you're running out of dog food,
you think the same thing would happen
with lifesaving medications.
But that's not the case.
The entire supply chain
has to be engaged.
So I thought,
what would it look like to partner
with the manufacturer and use prediction?
How do you get them?
She calls it
Project Protect,
anticipating
which drugs could go into shortage
and producing them
with other companies
before it's too late.
Their first effort,
the $100,000
grant to the for profit
stack pharmaceutical
to manufacture
two specific drugs,
potassium chloride and sodium chloride,
which newborn's non-ICU patients pick.
New patients need to survive
It's like salt and pepper.
You never think you're going to run out
of those very simple things.
Well, don't take our supply chain
for granted.
Jared Milton oversees
all pharmacy
and clinical services
at Children's Hospital, Colorado.
What Project Protect didn't exist?
What would have happened
in that situation?
I shudder to think about what
we would have had to do.
Potassium chloride,
one of the first drugs.
So you're able
to anticipate this shortage
basically at risk.
Create the medications
And they did go into shortage.
They did go into shortage.
And more than 700,000 treatments
were accessed.
And what we know. 700,000.
Yeah. That's incredible.
It is incredible.
And you see this now
or you see this coming off the line,
so to speak. What's that like for you?
What I see here is each
one of those is being filled up.
Seven to nine Nicky babies that
are going to get fed today.
How is Abby doing?
She is officially a survivor.
She's doing great.
She's a very normal, typical,
bright, clever, fierce.
13 year old.
John, we report a lot on drug shortages
and if you caught that.
But 300 drugs in shortage
at the end of 2022.
The average length of a shortage
is a year and a half.
I mean, it's
hard to believe
we spent
$4 trillion on health care
in this country.
And that's what we often
have to deal with.
And it's a challenging problem to fix.
But to get a determined mom like that,
and she makes a difference in the system.
That's what we need.
It's amazing,
wonderful that her daughter is doing okay
and now she wants to spread that
and keep it going for others
and making such a difference.
Sanjay, thank you. Great to see you.
So The Champions for Change one
hour special is Saturday night at 8 p.m.